this is the best friend you never knew
you needed the Rog Ally Asus Rog
strongly touts that this is better than
the stream deck it's more powerful more
compact it offers more frames and more
bang for your buck make sure to check
out comparison with the steam deck one
sets out in this video we'll be going
over all the juicy specs that includes
the two configurations it comes in with
AMD pushing their all-new ryzen Z1 and
Z1 extreme processes both have a 7 inch
1080p display that runs at 120hz in a
16x9 aspect ratio we'll get into it
later on we'll go with quick specs
before we get into my early impressions
of it again the Rog Airline comes in two
configurations which are the AMD ryzen
Z1 and Z1 extreme processors we have the
Rog Ally with the Z1 extreme chip so we
will be talking about that the ryzen Z1
extreme config has Zen 4 8 core and 16
threads 24m cash and CPU clocks up to
5.1 gigahertz into the GPU both the Z1
and Z1 extreme configs have AMD Radeon
Rd and E3 and 4 gigs Ram capacity but
the difference is at the default values
a model C use and of course GPU clock
memory wise we have 16 gigs LP ddr5 6400
megahertz dual Channel onboard memory
for storage the Z1 runs n.2 and vme 2230
gen 4x4 SSD 256 gigs and 512 gigs for
the Z1 extreme you can expand that
storage with the micro SD card as the
Ally has its slot available and this has
Windows 11 for its OS it runs just like
any other PC but it does feel kind of
clunky because you do have to navigate
using its touchscreen and on-screen
keyboard to launch other launches or
apps other than Armory cream you can use
the analog sticks and buttons but it's
easier if you just use the touchscreen
to click on what you need so far this
hasn't hindered my experience at all
here are the specs for the display again
it is a 7 inch 1080p 120hz 16x9 display
with adaptive sync y Cali gamut srgb 100
and A7 Ms response time with a maximum
brightness of 500 nits it also has
Gorilla Glass warning the XC coating
which helps reduce insulin light if
you're gaming on the go which basically
means you don't have to blast the
brightness when you're outside now onto
the console itself it's 608 grams which
is pretty lightweight it has two fans
and two front-facing speakers that
provide virtual 5.1 to Dolby Atmos
surround sound and supports high-res
audio and two-way AI noise cancellation
which filters out any background noises
from incoming and outgoing audio doing
voice chats fans are pretty quiet and
get sucked in from the back here and out
of the vents up top for ports we have a
Rog XG mobile interface and USBC combo
port a 3.5 in meter audio jack and a
Micro SD card slot this Rog XG mobile
interface combo is compatible with the
XC mobile where essentially you're
plugging in an RTX 490 and will turn
this Ally into a crazy gaming station
with just a connection it's sold
separately of course buttons and sticks
it pretty much has a layout similar to
an Xbox controller XY AV buttons your
analog sticks d-pad rnl buttons from
from one to three and also two macro
buttons at the back of the device you
also have four buttons for menus it
command center button to customize your
bindings a view button a menu button and
a dedicated Armory crate button before I
forget there is a volume button and the
power button also acts as a fingerprint
sensor now before we continue this
channel is supported by Brands who help
us improve our content and keep us going
so stay around for this sponsored
message if you are looking for a laptop
that does it all gaming streaming and
content creation then look no further
than the Rog surface M16 the first 16
inch laptop with an anime Matrix LED
array so you can showcase your inner
geek to the World featuring a 16 by 10
aspect ratio QHD Pantone validated Rog
nebula display this display not only
looks great but also offers
unprecedented performance thanks to its
240Hz refresh rate and 3 milliseconds
response time with all that power comes
with full width heatsink supported by
Rog intelligent cooling with tri-fan
technology to keep the laptop cool while
intense gaming or heavy workloads for
more details check out asus.com now at
the time of recording we do not have a
price for both devices yet but Asus said
it will be competitive to the steam deck
starting price of us 400 playing on this
is definitely a bit comfier than a steam
bag because it is lighter and it's
Corners kind of aim downwards so you can
really dig your palms to get a firm grip
on the front without having to worry
about hitting the touch pads that the
steam bag has and you won't be covering
the speakers the back is a different
story however I have huge hands so it
doesn't sit as comfortably but so far as
a whole I haven't felt my fingers or
hands cramped out in any way my muscle
memory for XBox controllers kicks in and
navigating the buttons and sticks will
feel like any other Xbox controller I
can perform on any FPS pretty decently
off the bat but with a bit more
adjustments it will be Flawless through
any game with this and you will have a
great time Khan beat the mouse and
keyboard experience of course but it
really is solid as is but what really
surprised me and I think many others is
how quiet the fans are the steam deck is
much louder than the Rog Ally when
you're playing demanding games like dark
tide or cyberpunk the fans go off like a
plane and you will have to crank up the
volume if you're playing without jacking
in the near piece or having earbuds on
the Ally doesn't have that issue even if
you bump it into turbo mode for the same
games which puts this way ahead of the
steam deck
you can also hit higher frame rates much
more comfortably because this is
definitely more powerful than a steam
deck because of the latest and greatest
from AMD the Allies display is great at
16x9 which fits most games so you won't
get the black boss you'd see with the
16x10 screen the audio is actually
pretty good even at the highest level
without any Distortion so far so you're
safe if you want to blast them but of
course for not too long the colors are
really good they aren't over saturated
and when you bump up the brightness you
don't lose much quality rg's Armory
create integration with Windows 11 is
okay and for those that don't know I'm
gonna create is a gaming Hub slash
launcher where you can launch games and
apps like you can also configure Rog
Centric settings and widgets note that
the Ally is not necessarily a console
it's more of a portable gaming PC with
Windows 11 on it that has Armory trade
integration and not the other way around
the steam deck is a console and you
enter big picture and its UI and only
after some tweaking can use the deck as
a PC you can of course download other
launchers like EA epic games and of
course steam which is already on here
but of course the device as a whole
lacks a true integration with steam's UI
or just any launches UI so it's not a
particularly smooth experience but it
does work alright it does take a couple
tries to let the games recognize the
Allies controller but once it does
you're set so the product is a little
finicky in its early stages there are
also three modes silent which runs
defense quiet performance which balances
out the Ally and turbo mode which pushes
the Ally to perform at its best
essentially lower medium higher
performance settings for my final
thoughts so far there is a lot to take
in with the Rog Ally we'll be taking a
more in-depth look with this soon and
compared with the steam deck but Asus is
really giving valve a run for their
money and is looking to be an extremely
fast competitor given how much more
powerful its CPU and GPU is and it's
obviously much better display it really
is an experience just having this
compact lightweight and handsome looking
console that embodies the saying walks
softly and carry a break guys and boy is
it silent and deadly for its competitors
oh but the question that tops off the
rest would you get it let me know in the
comments below and make sure to follow
us on all of our socials right here to
keep up with the latest news we put out
and if you like what you're seeing hit
the like And subscribe buttons it goes a
long way in helping the channel out if
you want to see more stuff check this
out
[Music]